what life lesson do you think you've
learned the hard way the value of Candor
there's nothing even close when I think
about every relationship I have on Earth
any employee that has ever worked at
Boehner or at Wine Library that doesn't
like me that knows me are 100 based on
my inability to be Candace with them and
then surprising them when they got fired
the reason I wrote 12 and a half was to
get that out and to talk about how I've
reframed it our company seven years ago
we didn't have cotton Candor we didn't
have it we are a much better company for
having Candor but Candor that has the
word kind in it because Candor is
weaponized by a lot of people